good morning my name is will thompson
i'm the director of engineering for
privacy dynamics today i'm going to give
you a very fast overview of data privacy
preserving methods uh through the lens
of us developing
the first version of our data privacy
service
so privacy dynamics set out with the
mission to be a privacy switch for the
modern data stack so we want to offer um
simple robust privacy controls for
modern data pipelines
and we started out
and our initial conversations with
customers led us to focus on uh data
sharing use cases and so this is where a
customer wants to take some data hand it
off to a third party safely and then
have them analyze the data
so
um what is data privacy in this context
we're talking about a data release and
so this is separate from
preventing access to data or um tracking
data access so we are focused on the
case where
we're protecting identities in data
when access has already been explicitly
allowed so
some important concepts to cover here
the first step towards identity
protection is to remove or replace
direct identifiers in the data and these
are like names addresses and phone
numbers and so this is called
pseudonymization
however
um
even though direct identifiers have been
removed from the data set combinations
of quasi identifiers things like
age zip code and
gender can be used to re-identify people
with high probabilities this is called
re-identification
also new information can be revealed
without linking using inference attacks
as this is uh if you query a database
multiple times to reveal new information
and so what we want to do is anonymize
the data also known as deidentification
and
what we do is we change quasi-identifier
values or personal attribute values and
this mitigates the risk that we are
going to leak sensitive information
about a person
and so another important concept is the
privacy utility curve and so what's
happening here is
we have to change data in order to
protect identities and so um every
method to protect privacy comes at the
expense of some accuracy and so the goal
is to find the
most acceptable trade-off for a specific
use case
and so the first method we explored is
global differential privacy and
differential privacy is defined as the
indistinguishability of a computation's
output when the input differs by one
individual's data and so what does this
look like
we have a data set we perform a
computation and then we get a result and
so then we take that data set add one
individual's data to it perform the
computation again and get
another result and what we can say is
the computation is
differentially private if the output uh
or the if the results are roughly the
same
and so
um we measure how roughly with epsilon
uh also known as a privacy parameter and
uh the closer epsilon is to zero the
more private we are and then the larger
epsilon uh the the more risk there is of
leaking information
and so
um
this is nice because it only adds noise
to a single statistic and so this leaves
us with high utility
differential privacy is unique in that
it's a strong guarantee and so this is a
absolute worst case scenario on
information loss and so from this we get
some important properties
one of these is composability so if you
perform
multiple computations on a data set and
you have epsilon values for each and you
want to know what the total information
loss is if you release all those
statistics
you can sum the epsilon values and
that's your total information loss
and then in addition
you don't have to make any assumptions
about what an attacker might already
know and what they might be
trying to get from you because this is
already a worst case scenario and so
these are really valuable properties
but
this didn't really fit our use case well
the way this works in practice is
you have to have a centralized system
that mediates
the queries between the analysts and the
data and then the centralized system
will return differentially private
results to the analyst and so
analysts have to use a centralized
system and instead of their own tools
and then also uh the centralized system
requires an element of trust because it
it
it holds the unprotected data
and then
ultimately in order to protect the
privacy we have to set an epsilon value
budget ahead of time and this is um
you set this budget and then analysts
query against the budget and then
there's there's a limit on what they can
do so this this implies that you need to
have some understanding of what queries
you need ahead of time and this doesn't
really work well for a lot of data
analysts who
prefer to use exploratory analysis to
understand their data
and so
uh
the next method we looked into is k
anonymity and this is uh is different
from differential privacy
can animate is a property the data set
whereas differential privacy is a
property of the algorithm and its output
and so
a data set is considered k anonymous if
each record's quasi identifiers match at
least k minus one other records so what
does this look like um we have a handful
of
uh quasi identifiers uh matching in a
data set and um they uh the equivalence
classes uh have uh varying uh levels of
matching
and we can see that there's one unique
value
so uh this is a k anatomy k anonymity is
similarly a worst case and so in this
case uh we have to say k equals 1 for
here so what we want to do is increase
this k value uh decrease the risk of
re-identification and so what we do is
we want to generalize some values and so
here we will take the unique value here
this line and we will
group them with the tiger and then we
can say they're all cats and so now uh
that unique row has been eliminated and
k equals 2. and so this is what it looks
like in some real data so here we have
two unique rows and then we can group
those unique rows with other rows and
here you can see in the top row
in the top group the h column has been
generalized to a range and in the second
group the zip code column has been
generalized and the hispanic column has
been
suppressed and so now
we've eliminated those unique growths
and so this is nice it protects whole
data sets so data can easily be shared
it it directly addresses linking attacks
and it's intuitive to think about
and then we also only have to
modify the data that is at risk
based on our threshold
and speaking of thresholds k n enemy k
anonymity is only a threshold metric and
so um
so what that means is this is an example
you have the same data set anonymized
using two different functions and you
can look at the distribution of
record level cannonimity and see that it
is different across these data data sets
despite the fact that the k anonymity is
five for both and so uh these would have
different real-world risk um so we need
more metrics to get a complete picture
of what's going on and so this is a
little bit more complicated
because it's based on the probability of
a successful attack so we have to
consider what might an attacker know and
what background information might they
have
in addition because it's probabilistic
this is a weaker guarantee than
differential privacy which is more of an
absolute
metric and so
it's a little squishier
and then
k values aren't composable like epsilon
and one of the problems that we ran into
is
uh the algorithms that are used to
generalize data um are optimization
algorithms these tend to be
quadratic or close to quadratic so it's
difficult to scale and so um this this
was difficult for us
and so that brings us to local
differential privacy and so
local differential privacy follows the
same uh definition of differential
privacy as global but it's applied to
the whole data set and so uh the
classical example of this is called
randomized response and the concept is
that you want to offer plausible
deniability to a survey respondent when
you're asking them for information on a
sensitive topic so the way this works in
practice is essentially you flip a coin
and then depending on the results of the
coin flip uh the person will either
answer truthfully or you flip the coin
again and then uh randomly enter yes or
no and so um
this method um
it originated in the 60s so it predates
differential privacy by decades but it
still meets the definition of
differential privacy and we can use the
formal definition to derive an epsilon
value uh which is approximately 1.1 and
so this is a pretty good epsilon value
and then note that um
we get 50 noise in this data set uh in
exchange for this epsilon value and so
um
you uh that was an uh example for binary
data um
we can also do this with numerical data
and so uh this is how apple uh handles
uh sending histogram uh information to
their systems uh from your devices and
so
this is similar to the survey
questionnaire this is applied client
side uh what they do is they take the
histogram
uh value it's encoded into a one hot
encoded vector and then using this uh
this probability here and epsilon is uh
in the denominator here uh
we swap every single value in the vector
on this probability and then now we have
uh produced a uh epsilon differentially
private vector and that goes to apple so
this protects whole data sets like
cannonimity
that's nice and it offers a strong
privacy guarantees like
and composable epsilon like global
differential privacy
but one of the difficulties here is that
differential privacy protects something
different from can anonymity which is
designed to directly address linkage
attacks and so it's difficult to
reconcile
epsilon and re-identification risk and
the issue is that in practice
you can have a large epsilon which would
indicate uh poor privacy but still have
low
risk and so this is difficult if um
linkability is what you're interested in
and then
the biggest problem for us is is local
differential privacy applies a lot of
noise uh orders of magnitude more noise
than global typically
so then finally uh we have synthetic
data and so this is um
idea here is you train a neural network
or some other machine learning model
on unprotected data and then you
generate an entirely different data set
and so uh
this seems like a pretty ideal way to
protect identities like intuitively you
would think
this is not personal information anymore
but
in practice this is not the case
synthetic doesn't automatically mean
private
it's still
vulnerable to inference and linkage
attacks and so you still need to apply
still need to apply noise to synthetic
data in order to protect it and so
once you've applied the noise then the
privacy utility tradeoff doesn't really
outperform any other methods and
there's because you're using this
generative model these models tend to be
more inscrutable and
the privacy gain and utility loss can be
very hard to predict
and so uh for that reason it's um it's
it's just tricky to use this in practice
but um
oh and then um the model training phase
is very expensive uh on average these
algorithms are more expensive than uh
can anonymity so so we would have a lot
of trouble scaling this um
but there is um
some new work has been done on
re-identification risk uh
uh instead of uh differentially private
uh assessments on this and so
there's potential for better utility
but
when you're addressing re-id risk
for synthetic data but this is some this
is some new work
um so
uh we came away not really satisfied
with any of these methods and so we
decided to pursue our own method and
address some of these other problems
based on can anonymity and after we
worked on this for a while we discovered
that we had kind of reinvented something
that mostly existed in the literature
called microaggregation and so micro
aggregation is similar to k anonymity
but
traditional can anonymity
is optimizing around a generalization
hierarchy and one of the problems we
have is that
it often results in over generalization
if the hierarchy isn't fit for any
specific data set and
also you end up mixing categorical
data these generalized data these
generalized values with the original
values so this makes it hard to
compute downstream for analysis and so
what microaggregation does is we use uh
cluster analysis
instead of
optimizing for a generalization
hierarchy and then in a second pass
we generalize the clustered values and
so we end up with higher precision
because we're able to cluster around the
closest values and then uh essentially
publish the the cluster's center and so
additionally since clustering happens
independently in the first step you can
replace generalization entirely with an
arbitrary aggregation function and so
uh we can publish a more accurate
aggregate value using something like me
median or mode and
at the same time we're maintaining the
semantics of the data to simplify
downstream analysis
and then
also since we're using clustering this
opens up possibilities for increased
precision around complex data types like
geographical data
and
in many cases where
generalization would force you to
suppress a value because you've reached
the top of the generalization hierarchy
you can just publish the mode
and
still have
more accurate data and
avoid suppression entirely so
um
there are several other things that we
had to address that i didn't have time
to get into in this talk uh but
uh
yeah this so this was our prop this was
our process for for implementing data
privacy to fit some uh customer needs
for our launch product and the key
takeaway here is that
you know every use case is somewhat
unique and so i expect that we will need
to add or augment our methods
to address new use cases as they come up
and so
the most appropriate methods for
addressing privacy depend not only on
the privacy utility trade-off but also
requirements for efficiency usability
and
data needs and trust
thanks i hope you found this talk
helpful